cardi means legal walls continue the
rapper missed a court appearance in New
York today
he's Brendan G offerin it's monitoring
the story Brendan why was Courtis of
cardi supposed to be in court today
right so she's let's be in court today
over an alleged strip club brawl that
occurred in August in which she
allegedly threw a chair at an unintended
target at the Angels gentlemen's club in
a neighborhood in New York City
hey Brendan did you ever think there'd
be a point in your career in which you
talk about an alleged strip club brawl
we're someone's leged Lea threw a chair
I didn't know no to be totally honest
where was she Brandon why is it a grand
story it's a show where she was yeah so
we actually just got in photos paparazzi
photos in which she's reportedly on the
beach in Miami at a music oh oh what's
like a little bit of a risque shoot if
you will too right yeah what I'm
confused about this look there's a lot
going on in this photo right now Brendan
what do we know about the brawl at the
at the gentlemen's club does this deep I
mean did she throw a chair was there a
big fight do we know that something
actually happened there so it's all
still reportedly allegedly people
claimed this with the police but we do
know that she was arrested back on the
1st of October and she was charged with
two misdemeanors those misdemeanors were
assault and reckless endangerment and
again after this after she turned
herself in to the NYPD on October 1st
so it's also allegedly until it all goes
through the courts well from what I've
read today Brennan it seems like the
judge has been you know pretty pretty
fairly nice since cardi didn't show up
today the judge is actually giving her
another opportunity to show up on Friday
what happens if she doesn't show up on
Friday what are the next steps for cardi
right some prosecutors today in court in
Queens they requested an immediate bench
warrant
for her arrest but the judge declined
that before issuing a serious warning
but she must appear in court
this coming Friday morning or an arrest
warrant would be a likely issued for her
so I have a good feeling that party is
gonna take the next play by the way I
hope she does because she is on top of
her game right now and I feel like this
is the last thing that should be just
messing up her flow you know and and
it's just something we just should not
have to worry about in cardi shoes I
hope she deals with it and it's left
from there on thank you absolutely no
problem guys thanks
[Music]